the city of ostrich located in the
southernmost tip of the Netherlands has
witnessed centuries of european history
Maastricht is believed to be the oldest
city in Holland and today its home to
some 120,000 people the historic city
center is a lively mix of cafes and
restaurants
once houses of worship the city's
massive moral limestone churches now
serve a different purpose ceiling
frescoes have been preserved though the
church no longer hosts religious
services
today it's been converted into a
bookstore in the 18th century Napoleon
converted the church into a horse stable
today the bookstore owner is more
careful with the structure hotels to
have sprung up in former churches
the Dino fanciful McGarrett can close
generating and rebuilding a church or a
monastery in to a hotel isn't easy mana
requires you to work together with
historic landmark officials about
alienation it's important to keep the
original architecture as it was believed
that's why the new hotel building was
essentially dropped right into the
church at or genelia cobalt left the
massive windows create a unique
atmosphere in the breakfast room one
floor down the hard choir stalls were
given a plush makeover and the
traditional Eucharist has made way for
rare wines elegant crossings connect the
original structure with the new and the
old art and architecture have been
paired with modern interior design
the patron saint of maastricht servatus
now grants his blessings for the new
hotel construction of the church and
monastery began in 1440 and they've been
remodeled several times amongst once
Spartan quarters have been turned into
luxurious hotel rooms
in 1797 the monastery and church were
converted for secular use the complex
was neglected for decades and near ruin
until the hotel owners decided to give
the structures a second life but there
is more to Maastricht than beautiful old
buildings there's plenty of new
architecture to take the province of LED
boards parliament building for example
the maastricht treaty was signed here in
1992 a milestone agreement that laid the
groundwork for what is today the
European Union just down the river is
st. Petersburg Hill which looks out over
the news river and surrounding areas
here hidden behind a cafe we find the
entrance to the northern caves a dark
underground labyrinth where the workers
extracted the materials used to
construct majestic building centuries
ago in 1770 historians studying the
moral core he came across some unusual
bones saying she must be dead before now
look at what we have here a dinosaur
Moses always connect it was named the
Moses are sore Muse lizard ya author I
was twenty meters long from there to
there but unfortunately the French came
along and took him away with him traces
of the most asaurus eras still remain
bought soda signs of the French
explorers who have ventured into the
dark caves hundreds of years later and
left messages about Napoleon
st. Petersburg's limestone help shape
the city centre of Maastricht creating
one of the most beautiful cityscapes in
the Netherlands today
you